ترغب [موسيقى]
[موسيقى] أجنبية
أيضًا في التحدث عن
مخاوف الأمن القومي التي أثارتها والتي
نأخذها على محمل الجد ،
اسمح لي أن أبدأ بمعالجة بعض
المفاهيم الخاطئة حول رقصة اللدغات التي
نحن شركة تابعة لها
عن طريق الرقص لا تملكها أو تتحكم فيها  من قبل
الحكومة الصينية ،
إنها شركة خاصة
[موسيقى]
أجنبية [
موسيقى]
لم أر أي دليل على أن
الحكومة الصينية لديها إمكانية الوصول إلى تلك البيانات التي
لم يطلبوها منا مطلقًا
ولكنك تعلم ما سألت عنه
لأنني وجدت أنني
بحثت في الواقع لم أر أي دليل
على حدوث ذلك ، ومن أجل طمأنة
الجميع هنا وجميع مستخدمينا ، فإن
التزامنا هو نقل البيانات إلى
الولايات المتحدة ليتم تخزينها على
الأراضي الأمريكية من قبل شركة أمريكية
يشرف عليها موظفون أمريكيون
[موسيقى]
أشكركم
أجنبية